from day one I've been accepted to go
out there and be Who I am and the my
teammates that they've responded by
being being great every single day and
so for me like I said I've been put in a
great situation I just try to maximize
it every single day Pat mahomes the
Chiefs quarterback with a great
performance on Sunday against the
Tennessee Titans and yet again Chris
here go the Chiefs falling behind down
10 nothing this week then down 17 to 7
and it really felt like the Titans had
the formula when they had that
nine-minute and seven second drive in
the second quarter where they pushed the
lead from 10 to 7 back to 17 to 7 I was
starting to have visions of Super Bowl
25 you remember Super Bowl sure of
course you remember what your dad's
Giants did yeah in the third quarter of
that game took up basically the whole
third quarter with one drive I mean if
the Titans could have put themselves in
position to have those slow methodical
grinded out drives in the second half
they could have put the Chiefs in
checkmate but man it woke up and it woke
up in a big way once they were down 17 7
the Chiefs Rochard to two touchdowns
take the lead going into the locker room
at halftime and I really felt like that
was it at 21 17 would they be able to do
in those two drives to end the half now
look they still had to come out and play
the second half obviously but it had a
much different vibe quickly in 6 minutes
and 39 seconds of clock time it went
from feeling like holy crap the Titans
are going to steal this one - ok the
Chiefs are still the Chiefs and the
Titans are still the time well and the
Chiefs are still the Chiefs and they're
not the same defense the Titans saw the
first time around as we saw there I mean
that's the first thing
yeah those first few drives were like
ooh this is concerning but they kind of
you know they kind of bucked up and all
of a sudden there was no there was no
run game to be had but the story of the
game is one thing and one thing only you
know the pressure was on Kansas City's
offense to deliver down 10 nothing then
down 17 7 and that's supposed to be
their strength of their team the
receivers the tight end the quarterback
and man they delivered and man I mean
hey Patrick mahomes if he didn't think
he was the best quarterback in the sport
you do now I mean it's just unbelievable
he's the story the game he's the
difference his composure his skills
said everything about it he's on another
level right now Mike he really is he's
just on another level
he's almost unstoppable because oh you
blitz oh ok he'll make a guy miss and
then make a big play oh you want to play
man-to-man alright well if he sees the
matchup he likes he throws it but who if
you're gonna play me man-to-man and
everybody's backs turned pine to man I'm
gonna scramble oh its own coverage oh
well I'll just slide around and move and
manipulate the zone and then find a hole
in it oh you can only rushing me in
three I'll just sit there all day and
then if nobody's open I'll go run and
find a hole like he's got it alright now
he can just he's got a great feel let
alone the talent he was a remarkable
yesterday he wills them to win games and
his talent just shines through he's the
best player in the sport right now two
AFC championships one Super Bowl in his
first two years starting as a
quarterback I just you can't say enough
about the guy he's amazing there was a
moment yesterday that I think for me
helped better understand how bad from
homes operates when he gets the ball and
he's in the pocket he had a lot of time
on one specific play yeah and he didn't
just stand there right right he's
constantly moving he is he never lets
himself get lulled to sleep in the
pocket like in Aaron Rodgers or others
may do Rodgers has the ability to run
away from pressure but if you if you get
you know kind of things are clean and
going well it's easy to stray away from
what's happening in front of you and
it's like Patrick mahomes is always
balancing what's happening down the
field what's happening in front of me I
see I let my guard down I'm never good
I'm always in that I gotta go gotta go
gotta go gotta go mode and he has the
perfect balance between that and his
ability to throw the football at any
time from any body position any platform
and I think it screams out when he
doesn't have to run that he's always in
that mode of I may have to run and I
think's gonna serve him well in 13 days
against those 49ers Pat's pressures that
can chase him around everywhere
well definitely and well and then Kansas
City can they can protect the passer I
mean that's the thing we saw yesterday
you know again you know we got into the
conversation with the 49ers of the
Packers and how you know the playoffs
you seem to always have to play that
team where your weaknesses kind of rise
to the top well Tennessee Titans their
weakness all year was
defense you know one because they
couldn't really rush the passer with for
all the time to get home and then they
weren't great in the backend they line
up a lot of yards well it all came back
to bite them in the butt in the end they
played the one team in the playoffs that
said oh you're not good at that well we
can really expose it we're gonna see how
much better you got at it during the
year and see if you sure that up and
they did not and yes I mean you're right
his his feel is intangibles just
everything about his game it really it
reminds me of an Aaron Rodgers back in
the early 2010-2011 where you just went
there's some teams he plays it just you
can't beat him it doesn't matter he's
gonna find out the specific formula in
this game and he found out the formula
yeah first three drives didn't know how
to really attack it but him and Andy
Reid figured out and then he figured out
the style of play to go with it
to expose it and then just you know just
again for the second week in a row once
they get it going night night because it
is it's just like it's the greatest show
on turf it's the Golden State Warriors
it's just like whoa we're feeling it and
it's a high-flying fun show to watch and
the pack of plays that we were showing
on NBCSN and on Sky Sports as we as you
were talking about that it really
amplifies my point and it reminds me of
DOC done and and they're they're redoing
top guns so this is you know that dated
reference but remember when they're
trying to get the the radar lock on the
plane like the defensive linemen can
never get a lock on him you never really
have a target with Patrick mahomes
because he's constantly moving so think
how frustrating it is you're trying to
get off your block you're trying to
figure out who you're going to but the
guy is always moving he'd never stand
still until the ball is out that's gotta
be frustrating as hell for a defensive
line brush trading and every bit is
exhausting for a defense as it is
playing some Smash Mouth running
football team I mean think about what
you're going through Mike right
everything you just explained you're a
defensive lineman who's going oh god
she's going this way oh gosh she's going
that way oh gosh wait he's standing
there let me go get him oh gosh she
moved again let me go run after him that
way the DBS in the back end there
whether they're in man or zone they're
having to cover for six and seven
seconds at a time
it wears a football team
he does it by himself with just his
magic that he pulls he's unbelievable he
really is for a kid as young as he is to
be the leader the talent everything he
is for that organization is just
astounding and he is the type of guy
that could break the Kansas City jinx
his talents so good yep haven't been to
a Super Bowl in 50 years great you get
Patrick mahomes you start him you go
back his second year starting that's
what kind of a special guy he is I can't
believe I apologize for a Top Gun
reference you're the guy that's good for
about three or four negative ghostrider
goes Rider the pattern is full yes
[Laughter]
Sammy Watkins seven catches 114 yards on
ten targets and you know we talked last
week about Tyree kill or Travis Kelce
who's gonna have the bigger day nobody
thought Sammy Watkins would be the guy
that blows it open but you know if
you're too focused on Kelsey if you're
too focused on Hill they got Watkins and
that was the issue last year Chris they
could never get everybody healthy right
same time you get those three guys
healthy at the same time they are very
difficult to slow down yeah I mean they
almost become unstoppable when all three
guys are healthy right like I mean we
talked about the Houston Texans and how
much better they are when when will
Fuller's healthy and what he does to
DeAndre Hopkins and and of course
deshaun Watson man when Kelsey Watkins
and Tyree kill and mahomes are hitting
on all cylinders
good night I mean you just good luck
it's almost it's almost impossible to
stop between Andy Reid's aggressiveness
his play design the way they can protect
mahomes he never settles right I mean he
never settles he rarely really makes
mistakes we don't look at him I got old
man you know he's a gunslinger again
that we go man he's a gunslinger but
it's just no no ball has ever seemed to
be thrown into a crowd nothing's ever
like ooh he got lucky there I mean
everything is just like the ball leaves
his hands and you go well I just have a
feeling somebody's gonna be on the other
end of this camera angle and they're
gonna catch it oh they did they caught
it he's a magic man he's the best player
in the sport right now and he is capable
of just about carrying this team or any
team to the Super Bowl and that's
it's gonna make it fun him versus the
49ers Wow I'm starting to think Chris
Sims you're gonna have one hell of a
time picking this game that you're not
gonna have an easy decision no between
49ers in Chiefs they match up the Chiefs
I think the 49ers are the better
football team from top to bottom but the
Chiefs match up well with the 49ers
you know they do some things that could
you know kind of like make the 49ers
strengths a moot point to a degree you
know the front four I don't think the
front for the 49ers just gonna be able
to get there by themselves all game long
like they did yesterday against Aaron
Rodgers not against this whole line and
now the way Andy Reed keeps you
off-balance with the movement and then
my home's moving to go along with it so
there's some interesting aspects of this
and as we've seen again hey we got to
stop questioning Kansas City's run
defense like this just in okay you know
they're good it's official we got to
stop questioning it it's been good for
about nine to ten weeks in a row now and
they slowed down the hottest running
back in football yesterday so that's
something to look forward to to with
Shanahan's run scheme verse Mack Nolan
that run defense I mean there's a lot of
cool things right Mike some would say
the Chiefs made Derek Henry a mute point
on Sunday the case may be a moot point
it's hardly a moot point though what the
Chiefs were able to do let's take a
break and when we return let's talk
about exactly how Derek Henry was unable
to continue a historic run and how the
Chiefs were able to bottle him up for
only 69 rushing yards on 19 attempt
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports